Apple's Mac OS is very similar to
Windows, Linux, and other operating
systems in a number of ways. One of
these is the way that Mac OS uses file
types. This is an extension that is put
onto the end of a file name that
commonly denotes what that particular
file is used for. For example, if you're
using Microsoft Word, then you've
probably seen a DOCX extension. If you
have compressed files, they may be
compressed with zip and you have a
dotzip extension. In Mac OS, we have a
number of important extensions you need
to know about. One of them is the DMG
extension. This is an Apple disc image.
This is very similar in functionality to
an ISO image, but it is specifically
made to work on a Mac OS device. If you
were to mount that DMG file, it would
look as a drive inside of your Apple
Finder. Another important file type in
Mac OS is the pkg file type. This is an
installer package and it's used to
distribute software. Instead of running
setup.exe like you would in Microsoft
Windows, you install an application that
has a pkg extension and it runs through
an installer script on your Mac OS
desktop. And in Mac OS, we don't have
.exe files. We instead have app files. A
stands for the application bundle. This
is a little bit different than an
executable because an app file contains
many different files inside of it. It is
indeed a bundle and you can view this
bundle of files by right mouse clicking
in the finder and choosing view package
contents. So although you're
doubleclicking on this app file to start
an application, it's really accessing a
number of different files that are held
within this application bundle. From the
end user's perspective, they never see
this bundle of files. All they see is
the app file and they can doubleclick
that file to start their
application. Mac OS also has an app
store. This is a centralized repository
of applications, updates, and a way to
centralize all of these patches under
one application. If you're wondering if
there are updates to a particular
application or you'd like to know if
application updates have already been
installed, you can start the App Store
application and click on the updates
option to see what the most recent
updates are. This can be set up to
automatically install these updates so
you never have to think about it. Your
applications are automatically updated
when they're made available to the App
Store. Or you can choose to install
these manually. So, you can go through
this list and manually choose what
applications you would like to update
and when you would like to update those.
And if you'd like to get a much larger
list of all of the applications that are
installed and their latest status, you
can click the user ID and name down on
the bottom left of the app store.
Applications in Mac OS usually don't
have an uninstall application. To remove
an application, you simply delete the
app file. it goes into your trash and
the application is uninstalled. This is
one of the benefits of having an
application bundle. To get rid of all of
the files associated with that
application, you simply delete the
entire bundle. However, there may be
times when you have an application that
does have a formal uninstall program.
You simply start the uninstall program
and it will go through the process of
formally uninstalling the app from your
Mac OS machine. For example, this
Logitech gaming software app includes an
uninstaller.app and you can run that
program to remove everything associated
with the Logitech gaming
application. Just as Windows has special
folders for holding user documents or
storing program files, we also have
special folders within Mac OS. One of
these special folders is the
applications folder. And as the name
implies, this is the folder that
contains all of the applications that
you've installed. This is very similar
to the program files folder that you
might see within Windows. So it's one
place to go in your finder that says
applications and it lists out every app
that you can access in Mac OS. And of
course, these are application bundles.
So if you want to uninstall an
application, you simply highlight it in
the applications folder, hit the delete
key, and it is uninstalled from your
system. And just as we have a users
folder in Windows, we also have a users
folder in Mac OS. This is where all of
our user documents are stored. And there
will usually be multiple folders within
the user folder, one for each user that
logs into that system. I pin my user
folder on my left side favorites list.
And you can see here there is a
professor folder that has a little house
next to it. That is my home directory.
and it's found under slash
users/professor. There are some folders
in Mac OS that are used by multiple
people who have access to this system.
One of these is the slash library
folder. This is a library folder that is
just off the root of the Mac OS file
system. These are support files such as
scripts, fonts, and other files that may
be used by multiple applications and by
multiple users on the system. Each user
also has their own library folder. We
usually designate this as a tillday/
library. This means it's your home
directory and within your own home
directory is a library folder. If you
went into users professor, you would
also find a users professor library. For
example, these are files that normally a
user would not need access to. And by
default, this folder is hidden within
the finder. You can still directly
access this folder of course. So if you
need to do any troubleshooting, you can
always go directly to the tillday/
library folder. And of course, we need
somewhere to store all of the important
operating system files for Mac OS. And
in this operating system, we store them
under /system. This is very similar to
the files that we might store under a
back/ Windows directory on your Windows
computer. If you own an Apple device,
then you're probably already aware of
the Apple ID. This is an identification
that you use to log into your Apple
device that designates that device as
belonging to you. You would normally use
that Apple ID with all of the Apple
devices you own. So when you purchase an
app on one device, that appears on all
of the other devices that you're using.
If you're using an Apple device for
business, then you don't want to use
your personal Apple ID. Instead, you
would use a managed Apple ID. This is
something that's managed by the company
through an application called the Apple
Business Manager. This also integrates
with Active Directory. So, you may be
able to use the same username and
password you use for your Windows
infrastructure to integrate into your
Apple infrastructure. This also allows
connectivity with an MDM or a mobile
device manager so that you can manage
all of these devices from one central
point. And of course, the person
managing all of these devices for the
organization can use Apple Business
Manager to move apps, assign
permissions, and coordinate the access
of data among all of these different
devices. Backups are an important task
that can often resolve a number of
different problems you might run into.
And there is a backup application
included with the Mac OS operating
system called Time Machine. Time Machine
provides automatic hourly backups to a
centralized Time Machine server. And
since this backup is occurring behind
the scenes, you can use Time Machine to
go back in time to find exactly the file
you're looking for. Time Machine also
creates daily backups for the past
month, and you can get weekly backups
for all previous months before that. Of
course, there's only so much space on a
backup volume, and Time Machine will
begin to delete the oldest documents as
you begin running out of space on your
Time Machine
volume. Although there are some
anti-malware features built into the Mac
OS operating system, there's no single
application you can use to check anti
virus or anti-malware features. However,
there are many different third parties
that create security software for anti
virus or anti-malware that you can
install on Mac OS. And although the vast
majority of malicious software is
written specifically for Windows, there
is still dangerous software that can be
installed on a Mac OS operating system.
You of course still need to use best
practices for security regardless of
what operating system that you're using.
And if you are using thirdparty
software, it might be a good idea to
increase the frequency of updates to
make sure that you are always able to
identify the latest
malware. Mac OS also includes an
automated process for updating the
operating system itself. This software
update feature can be found under your
system settings in the general section
and it's under software updates. This is
different than the updates you have in
the app store, which are really focused
on individual applications. This part of
the software update features inside of
your system settings, is designed for
updates of the operating system itself.
You also have control over what type of
updates are installed. For example, you
can choose to download new updates the
moment they're available. You can
install Mac OS updates or choose not to
install updates to the core operating
system. This is also where you can tell
the app store to install application
updates automatically. And there's also
a section for installing security
responses and system files, and we'll
talk about those in just a moment. You
also have the option for installing beta
updates. These are updates to the
operating system that have not been
released yet by Apple and are generally
in a testing phase. This feature is not
turned on by default, and you want to be
very careful about turning on beta
updates because some of these updates
are not fully tested and could cause
problems with your operating
system. Many of the patches that we have
for our operating systems are things
that we can install normally every
month. These may not be high priority
updates, but may be important to keep
the operating system running at peak
efficiency. But occasionally there may
be a security issue that needs to be
patched immediately and the Mac OS
operating system includes a way to do
this through the rapid security response
or RSR. You'll find the option to
disable rapid security response under
the options included in the automatic
update section. This last option for
installing security responses and system
files is turned on by default. This is
also a feature available in iOS and iPad
OS. So if you're using an Apple iPhone
or an iPad, then you have this option
also available in those operating
systems. This allows Apple to push out
these updates immediately if there is a
critical security issue. And if they
have sent out an update, they will
modify the number associated with the
operating system version. And if you
happen to have a letter next to the OS
version, that means that it has received
a rapid security response update.